[Musica]
c'è c'è un video in questo ipod che
premiamo prevediamo che i video è se
stai vedendo questo libro vuol dire
tenuto da meno attenta non svegliarmi
quindi perché poi serbo per te
alcune prove delle prove ho sparso nella
stanza beh 4 biglietti con quattro prove
che dovrai superare per insegnarmi segni
sveglierai per più di due volte
vorrà dire che hai perso è davvero un po
[Applauso]
sembra un po inizia a cercare le prove
allora ma ricordati dovrei fare silenzio
bene ok
iniziamo a cercare queste carte con le
prove ce la metterò tutta
vediamo chi vincerà tra me e il lupo
[Musica]
ok allora iniziamo a cercare queste
carte prova mentre il lupo dorme
importante non svilupparlo
ho trovato la mia prima carta prova cosa
si è iscritto cammina sui leggo è
possibile contare su leggo faccio
camminare senza fare rumore
procopio vincere la challenger farcela
diamo il via alla prima prova
è stato picchiato forte in berlino sta
giocando con incentivi potente con
trombette
ecco credevo capitarci sombra mangia non
c'era scritto senza può camminare scalza
o senza punto un e quindi i cammini non
con le pantofole così fanno un po meno
male
[Musica]
o no ha perso la prima prova non posso
perdere altre volte anzi non posso
perdere più di due super difficili dai
che fanno un sacco timore hanno fatto
più rumore
leggo che cadevano che io che si passa a
berlino ma ma ma dove hai preso
quell'eco mettila posto altrimenti il
lupo si arrabbia non puoi rubarlo così
va beh l'importante che non passa rumore
non so perché berlino si è messo a fare
un sacco di rumore non appena iniziata
la prova se si fosse messo d'accordo con
il lupo
dovrò stare attenta anche a berlino non
so se posso fidarmi questa volta perché
anche lui è una sorta di cane lupo forse
comunque ora cerco la seconda prova e
speriamo che sia più facile
non c'è
la seconda prova rami ti mangia i
crackers perché l'iter spalle un sacco
di rumore
beh però questa dovrebbe essere più
facile vediamo se ci riesco ok ragazzi
del gruppo che dorme e il sentito il
rumore di sottofondo il merlino che sa
sperano che hanno leggo ma glielo
lasciato perché così almeno non fa
ancora più rumore ma stati la in
corridoio
penso di riuscire a vincere questa
challenger maniera molto più semplice
delle altre
ora inizia a mangiare cercando di
trovare piano
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma cosa pensavo di aver perso piano
quatour cracker voleva mangiare rubarmi
il caracas si è svegliata e tecnicamente
mangiato greca cioè si è svegliato ma
non per il rumore del cracker moto che
volevano già tre che qui ho passato
questo probabilmente non li ho passato
una e se tutto ciò è molto strano
cerchiamo un altra prova adesso per i
ragazzi
abbiamo vinto una prova la seconda ora
cerchiamo la terza prova e vediamo cosa
c'è nel frattempo berlino continuando a
rosicchiare il suo leggo ovviamente a
fare rumore proprio quando non devo fare
un rumore cercava la prova forse
nascosto
gli stessi picasso è sempre d'aiuto
ecco la terza prova allora si è scritto
cammina sui leggo giganti già ho perso
la prima prova sera a camminare suolo
normali figuriamoci su quelli giganti
non ce la farò mai
dobbiamo provarci però speriamo di
riuscirci e poi le così chianti che
riescono a reggere i nostri menti farò
un sacco di catino staccato e praticate
da tempo lido nel frattempo sta
rosicchiando ancora il letto è l'ora di
stato come qualsiasi cosa
[Musica]
questo invece no berlino
[Applauso]
sono riuscita a passare lei camminarci
sopra di questi pazienti aspettato
pronte berlino diamo da fare un sacco di
casini no a berlino stesso di progettare
forse qui va quindi ho superato la terza
prova
ora mi manca solo la quarta programma
vediamo se c'è qualcosa qua nei pupazzi
non mi sembra di vedere niente
ditemi se poi potete qualcosa qua in
giro forse qua dietro
[Musica]
no non c'è niente mannaggia
ecco la quarta prova vediamo che ti fai
un castello di carte e tipicissimo può
fare il castello con le carte avete
presente e crolla quasi sempre perché
troppo difficile ce l'avrò mai
fate il tifo per me proviamo ragazzi il
castello di carta ho trovato in parte
girarsi forse più facile marino continua
a fare rumore questi pezzi di lego
quindi non colpiti
che non ci vai
[Musica]
ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]
fai che facciamo partito berlino marino
marino ciao
questo è l'ultimo crociate
[Musica]
ho perso la seconda prova per colpa di
merlino ma non solo perché anche io non
riuscivo a fare il castello di carte
quindi la challenge è finita in parità
purtroppo non ho vinto meglio né il lupo
perché il lupo si è svegliato due volte
e io ho vinto due volte e ho perso due
volte lasciati un bel mi piace se volete
vedere una seconda parte in cui proverò
a vincere sarà la mia mente se questo
video raggiunge i 15 mila mi piace
faremo la seconda parte è consigliateci
pure nei commenti che altre prove di
silenzio volete vedere ora uil a secco a
4 cappelline su cui cliccare per vedere
i nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione
ciao